for these two Berlin is a big adventure
Frank Collins in G is a tax official
back home in Malawi and lon da cosa
works in the South African finance
ministry today they're tourists but
actually they're here in the German
capital to study chosen by a panel of
judges and my special for me this is my
best time to get out of our country and
of all places coming to Berlin in
Germany I was one of the best things
that has ever happened to me in my life
they're here in Berlin for a year and a
half on a postgraduate course in tax law
it's been something of a culture shock a
bit of like a coldness maybe I just
never right for it forward cuz I can you
know in Africa we just Charlie we love
home you know and yeah there is that
keeping to yourself and sometimes it's
not that movie I think especially with
the older generation the next morning at
the Berlin school of economics and lon
27 Africans from 13 countries are in the
program it's subsidized by the German
government back own and students work
for tax and fiscal authorities there
professor says this master's degree
course should prepare them to deal with
international tax law
by spids5 ad for instance taxation of
cross-border transactions many of them
have never had anything to do with the
international taxation they're hearing
about it for the first time oda and some
who deal with corporate taxation don't
know about income tax that's what yoga
so it's important for them to work in
groups or with case studies also to find
out how it is in other African countries
if you text bill then you have a docking
station so happy how do you tax an
employee who lives in one country and
works in another many of the students
think taxes need to lose their bad
reputation only way koza says that in
many countries they're often equated
with corruption corruption is a big
issue everywhere not just in South
Africa I think that we need to make
people understand what's happening with
their tax money I think from a
government perspective and it is that
educating people in terms of how we're
spending the money and where the money
actually goes to just to ensure that
people who actually receive the money I
actually spending it for the right
course most of the people back home they
have a negative perception of Taxation
and therefore in the end we have low
compliance they simply think taxes are
just a form of government stealing from
people they do not appreciate the fact
that access are for them when they're
not studying their thoughts are often
with their families and friends at home
keeping in touch is sometimes difficult
because the internet doesn't always work
it's not it's not coming up it's very
frustrating so because you just want to
talk and share experiences that they run
at home find out how everyone is doing
at home and so it's sometimes a bit
tough hey girlfriend I see because on
the one hand there's homesickness and on
the other the ambition to successfully
finish their studies in Germany
to grab the paper Frank Collins injuries
as his family is proud he's able to take
this course although he adds that their
expectations are now quite high it would
not make sense for me just to after they
are face this course I stayed behind to
me my conscience really puts me back so
i would love as much as possible to go
back home and still contribute something
they've already finished some of their
exams and now they plan to enjoy their
summer in berlin